what I want to do in this video is
further connect our understanding of the
binomial theorem to combinatorics to
Pascal's triangle and so just to review
the ideas again if we're taking X plus y
to the third power and I'm just using
this as an example that's a little bit
easy to get around get our heads around
that's essentially taking three
equivalent expressions and multiplying
them by each other you're taking X plus
y times X plus y times X plus y so let's
call this the first X plus y the second
X plus y and the third X plus y and so
if you're looking at the expansion of it
and you're saying well how many ways how
many ways if we're how many ways can we
construct XY squared or another way to
think about it is you have these three
expressions you're going to choose two
of them to contribute a Y and take the
product so for example you could pick
expression 1 and expression 2 to
contribute the Y you could pick
expression 1 and expression 3 to
contribute the Y or you could take
expression to an expression 3 to
contribute the Y and of course the other
expression is what's going to contribute
to the X so you have 3 expressions you
have 3 expressions and you're going to
choose to you're going to choose 2 to
contribute the Y and so that's why you
have this combinatorics idea it's 3
choose 2 it's the exact same
mathematical problem if you have 3
friends and you're choosing to to ride
in a car with you you don't care what
seat they are going to sit in you're
just saying which two friends get to
ride in my two-seater or get to ride
that what are the two friends that I am
going to pick same way here out of the 3
friends which are the two that I'm going
to pick to contribute a Y to this
product and then the third is going to
contribute an X now let's go to Pascal's
triangle and hopefully see that this is
actually a very similar idea so we could
go to the same term so the XY squared
term so that's right over there and
Pascal's triangle
I always visualize it as a map so this
is a node in the map and I think well
what are the different ways that I can
get to this node on the map well I could
have a I could have a y squared I could
have a Y squared and then multiply by an
X and since we're multiplying an X
that's why I made this line orange or I
could have an X Y and I could multiply
by a blue so there's there's two
immediate things above it that I can get
to them but there's two ways to get to
this one there's one way to get to this
one and so the combined ways to get to
this one is two plus one is equal to
three and just to make it the connection
between what we just said what's really
going on here is each at each of these
nodes as we pick a path we're
essentially saying are we picking an X
or Y from each of these expressions so
we number the expressions let's number
them here so let's say this is
expression 1 this is expression 2 this
is expression 3 so we said that there's
three paths that we could take us here
so let's let's mark them out so there's
there's this path there's this path
right over here that gets us there and
that's equivalent to picking the X from
expression 1 notice we pick the left
hand side then we go to the right hand
side we pick the Y from expression 2 and
then we pick the Y the Y from expression
3 the last two we pick the right path we
picked the blue path so that's
essentially one way that we could choose
to wise out of these three expressions
once again one way to choose two wise
out of three expressions but we don't
care about just that one way we care
about all of the different paths so this
was one way another way would be to go
like this so to pick a Y from the first
one an X from the second one and a Y
from the third one or pick a Y from the
first expression a Y from the second
expression and an X from the third
expression so it's really at the at kind
of a fundamental mathematical level it's
solving the exact same problem so
hopefully this gives you a little
intuition on why Pascal's triangle is
connected to combinatorics and why
they're both useful for finding binomial
expansions